[موسيقى]
كانت بيتنا قبل وعشره بيها طفولتنا
ومن الوالدتي الله يرحمها الى وقتنا
فجوهان قال هذه كنيسه قديمه قال انتوا
اولويه تحرشوها ما كان عندهم ما تقول
مشاكل انه هذا المسيح وهذا مسلم المسلم
والمسيحي بالاردن اخوان
[موسيقى]
انا علي الحمد الحكيطات حارس موقع اثري
خربه المخيم متوارثها عن هذه وعن اهلي من
الثلاثينات لغايه الان
[موسيقى]
تحكي لي الوالده انا ما كان لا فيه لا
طريق ولا كان في مستشفى النادم
فخذاتي وخلفتني بحفظه الكنيسه جوه انا
خلفتك الكنيسه
الموقع هذا فيه حوالي اربع كنائس تعود الى
الاسرى
البيزنطيين بالوادي
وكنيسه بالجبل المنطقه العلويه هذه كلها
تعود على العصر
من 562 ميلادي
هاي الكنيسه كنيسه سانلوط
[موسيقى]
للعائله قديم قبل الثلاثين
وكان لعايشين بها
[موسيقى]
دور الحجر وطين العقد القديم وكانت
ارضيتها كلها تراب
هذه حاله الناس كانت قبل
وكانوا عايشين بها قسم العامي وقسم
الوالدي فكان يطهو في القهوه والشاي
والشهاض على النار
النار سابقه على ما يدروا عنها انا
تحت التراب فتحفل الوالده تحكيلنا انها
حبرت النار بين هذا
اللوحات فكشفوا عنه
لوحات حلوه
بلغوا عنها فجوهان قال هذه كنيسه قديمه
وقالوا انتوا تحرسوها
وتحافظوا عليها تستقبل الشيعه من
الثلاثينات
لغايه وقتها
الفنانه اللي صمم هاي الرسومات عن عملهم
اليومي ناس يعصر العنب وناس على اليرغول
عشان بقصب عصير وناس يجمع العنب هيا على
الحيوانات وهذا يحمل السله وهذا كلب رائع
الغنم
وهذاك يحميهم من الحيوانات المفترسه زي
الدب الايطان وبرمه وهذا يحميهم من الاسد
ضربوا بالسهم عفوا رسمات اربع شجرات يعدن
من فصول السنه الاربعه
واجور اثنين على الشعله والحيوانات اللي
كانت عايشها زي الغزلان النعام
وهناك رسمات نهر في سمك وبط وهيئه الكتابه
يونانيه
ترجموها يعني دعاء
وتاريخ الكنيسه انه هاي اللوحات ثم مات
بخمسمائه
[موسيقى]
استمريت يعني من الواحد بعد ما توفت الحجه
الله يرحمها
[موسيقى]
مؤسسه يساعد محمد ابو علي
ان ولدت فيه واجنبيه العمر كله من الصعب
ان الانسان يتركه وان شاء الله انا نحافظ
عليها
[موسيقى]